terraforming Mars is my favorite board
game it's by far the game I've spent the
most hours playing and I feel like I
have a pretty deep understanding of the
game at this point so I decided to make
this sort of elaborate strategy guide
for the game here's a list of what the
20 videos will be containing if you want
to you can go to the end of this video
to see all the tips I have for you in
this video and also in the next one I'll
give you tips to help you win without
going into too much detail and then I
will elaborate on some of these points
in future video at least that was the
idea but I find myself incapable of
keeping things short and to the point so
some of these tips will be fairly long I
like to talk you have been warned I
expect you to know the rules of the game
but beyond that these tips are helpful
to beginners as well as high skill
players so grab a plug of cheese from
the fridge put on subtitles because the
subtitled the whole thing and let's get
into it tip number one realize that
terraform imas is an Indian building
game and play accordingly Mega Credit
First VP later this might be stating the
obvious I think most players are aware
of this concept but terraformiles is a
really complex game and I do have a few
things to say on this topic and in the
beginning you need money income I'm
using the term money income a bit
Loosely here but here's exactly what I
mean here's an equation I made money
income is literally anything that gives
you make a credit steel a titanium so
you can buy stuff during the game Mega
credit production is the best you can
get steel and titanium production is
good TI is fine but somehow it's a
little worse than make a credit
production just because Tia tend to be a
bit expensive in comparison but
sometimes you won't have any make a
credit production in your opening hand
and in that case Tia is a good plan B
actions and effects refer to cards you
just straight up give you Mega credits
like it could be Martian rails or mid
Industries although these two examples
are usually better in the mid game to be
honest and finally when I say discount
on cards it could be any of these but
just to give you a frame of reference
both catapult has a discount card value
of two and the reason the squares is
well I have autistic Tendencies and also
it's just to emphasize that the more you
can stack these discount cards the
better discount cards sort of kind of
Stack exponential really I think then
you might be thinking what about cards
where's cardrow in this equation what
are cards worth here's my opinion a
random card is worth about three Mega
credit on average in a two-player game
random cards are worth a little more and
the reason for this is the two player
games tend to be longer in terms of
generations which means that the games
are greedier which then mean that the
card strategy is extra good I'll get
back to that so you could actually make
the argument that a random card is worth
4 Mega credits in a two-player game
specifically and yet it is still not
that simple the thing about cards is
they're worth more if you have a lot of
money income I actually make a second
question to explain the relationship
between cards and money income so money
incomes times cards per generation equal
to your efficiency number and if your
efficiency number exceeds a thousand
then you have a officially gone
god mode
and you will surely win the game notice
that I'm saying multiplied not plus
basically you need to have a balance of
both card draw and money income to get
the best value if you have a ton of Mega
credit production but you have no card
draw then naturally a random card is
worth a lot more than three Mega credits
and if you have a ton of cards but
you're still stuck on zero Mega credit
production there are random cards as
worth a little less than three Mega
credits unless of course you have so
terrible cars and you're desperately
trying to draw some sort of Mega credit
production but you get the point if you
can get card draw and money income this
is how you can go God mode I'll talk
more about the card strategy and go God
mode in episode 3. now it's important to
understand that a TR equals a VP plus a
mega credit production I know it's not a
hundred percent the case because of
stuff like the terraformer Milestone and
the bank award and bonuses and minor
things like this but volunteer purposes
a TR equal to VP plus a mega credit
production the reason this is useful
information is that this will help you
to evaluate cards so nuclear zone for
instance now we know this is basically
two Mega grip production and a placement
bonus which is actually not complete
awful for building your engine as a rule
of thumb a TI is worth 8 Mega credit
throughout the game this holds true in
the first generation and in the last
generation however I still couldn't
quite make my piece with it completely
because I feel a TR is worth a little
less at the beginning of the game like
if you think about it if you're playing
helion where heat can be used as Mega
credit and then you really want to buy
something nice for your heat rather than
just transforming 8 heat into a
temperature sometimes you're going to do
this and it's fine but it doesn't feel
good preferably we want to spend your
heat as money on something better so
this is my reasoning I actually also
made a graph that encapsulated exactly
how I look at terraforming masks in
terms of the engine building aspect of
it and as you can see I did end up
putting a TR to 7 Mega Credit in the
early game I will talk about this in
more detail in episode 7 but basically
the orange line here that is almost
straight is the VP like we talked about
it's sort of Aid throughout the game but
I had to make it 7 in the beginning of
the game then the green line is Mega
credit production and the blue line is
VP so if you are an experienced server
foreign Mass player I would argue that
this is where we're at I know it's a
little bit extreme to say that a VP is
only with one Mega Credit in the
beginning of the game but it's more like
this is a mindset I think you should be
having and to be fair it's only if the
game goes to 14 Generations that it's
worth one but if you are a new player or
maybe even for the average player to be
honest these values might be a little
bit too low if you want to you could
just add one to all the TR and VP and
then this might actually be correct for
the new players so instead of like a VP
being worth one Mega Credit in the first
generation than a VP would be worth two
Mega credits in the first generation and
the reason you can adjust it in this way
is because new players are just
naturally not as efficient in investing
their Mega credits which makes sense um
here is a much simpler representation
much easier to remember these are
probably the values to live by so in the
first generation a ts8 in the last
generation cs8 easy to remember and then
the only thing you really have to keep
in mind is that VP is lower in the early
game and then at at the end of the game
it jumps up to 8 Mega credit and then
Mega credit is worth 5 to begin with and
this is I think this is a fair value for
for the newer players to be honest now
in case you're wondering what I think
like everything is worth an average
um there you go I'm not gonna spend time
on it now because I have an entire
episode dedicated to this if you really
want to you can pause the video but I'm
gonna move on now all of these graphs
and equations here are sort of Overkill
and you could argue completely
unnecessary I will stop now I promise
the point I'm trying to make is actually
pretty simple one income in the early
game good money come in the late game
bad VP in the early game good but no bad
and VP in the late game is of course
good here's another way to explain it
tip number two in the early game focus
on climbing out of the hole at the start
of the game you're in a hole and your
first priority in every single game
should be to climb out of this hole the
whole is a metaphor that you're poor is
basically what I'm saying at the start
of the game you only have a money income
of 20 because you start with 20 tier
this is nothing in the second generation
if you buy all four cards and that's 12
Mega credits then you only have eight
Mega credit is that nothing you cannot
play the game if you have only 8 Mega
credits so your first priority must be
to climb out of the hole and you do this
by you guessed it money income
especially Mega credit production if
you're playing with the colonies Luna is
really good even if it is a standard
project that costs 17 Mega credit if you
have building tags in your bidding hand
then a colony in Cirrus is reasonable
and so on if you are playing a five
player game specifically where the games
are shorter and the scores are lower you
could also have VP and especially Tia in
the back of your head even as soon as
the first generation in five player
games it's actually entirely reasonable
to just build your engine with mostly TR
but even then you still play the mega
credit production card you get in the
early game so it could make the argument
that fair play games are slightly
different but as a general rule your
first priority should always be money
income in the start of the game right
now what I want you to take away from
this is this mindset of money first VP
later so just instantly you know that
indentured workers and lunar exports
where you choose the mega credit
production are great cards on your
opening hand whereas cards as Aero break
ammonia asteroid and into the star
Colony ship are bad cards in your
opening hand error break ammonia Astro
is just way too expensive and the Heat
and plant production is not really what
you're looking for in the first
generation at least not for this price
an Interstellar Colony ship gives you
literally only VP so that's not good in
the early game either so you might be
thinking why is indentured workers a
good car it gives you negative VP yeah
yes but in the same spirit that I don't
really care about positive VP in the
girly game I don't really care about
negative VP either like if you think
about it this card basically gives you
at least five Mega credits y5 because
the car itself got three but five Mega
credits with accumulated interest in
12th generation could easily be worth 5
Points maybe even 10 parts so literally
always keep indentious workers in your
opening hand it's really good in episode
8 I will rank the cards and I will tell
you specifically which cards I would
keep in my opening hand and then I'll
also talk about drop cards cards like
these that look great but they're really
not that good in the first generation
and so we got Phobos basehaven and house
printing they can be good in the mid to
late game actually because they do have
VP attached to them designed
microorganisms was okay if you need the
science tag but preferably you want to
play this after you get some money
income and then it it's kind of awkward
that this has a maximum 14 degrees
requirement I mean just don't get baited
into thinking that this card oh this is
overpowered because why else would it
have a maximum requirement it's really
not that overpowered these cards are
more like a plan B if you literally have
no good cards in your opening hand so
trap cards are cards in your starting
hand that look good but are really not
that good which means that error break
the money asteroid underground
destinations are technically not trap
cards because these cards never look
good here is a rule of thumb that can
help you to spot these trap cards tip
2.5 engine building cards should pay for
themselves in 5 or fewer Generations if
it's very only the game I might actually
be okay if the card takes 6th generation
to pay for itself but it really doesn't
feel good sometimes cards like let's say
immigration shuttles are okay if you
have literally nothing better to build
you into with remember the card itself
costs three so this card takes a little
more than six generations to pay for
itself in this case the card also
provides some VP but nevertheless it's
still on the slow side to be honest the
later the game you get the faster engine
building cards must be able to pay for
themselves so be really careful what you
choose to do with your mega Credit in
the first few Generations this really
does matter a lot and if you do not
climb out of the hole then the hole
itself the hole right it will become
a black hole and in the black hole
you'll stay poor for the entire game and
your score is gonna suck and you're
gonna lose horribly don't get black hole
people tip number three in the mid to
late game you need to make the
transition from engine to VP grabbing
this is equally as important as engine
building is engine is only good for the
first half of the game in the second
half of the game you need to get all the
VP you can get I think the sweet spot
for win to get VP like crazy is maybe
when there's four generations left of
the game however pure Victory Point
cards should really be played in the
very last generation tip number four
please grab the free bonuses attached to
the temperature oxygen and venuscale
I'll go into more detail in episode 6
timings but basically the important
thing is that you consist these three
bonuses they are important so we got the
temperature bonus on the oxygen scale we
got the water placement bonus and the
heat production bonus on the temperature
scale and then if you're playing with
Venus we also got the card bonus and the
TR on the Venus scale a few different
things you can do to get the bonus first
of all you can keep cards that help you
to get the bonus
so we got Damas down for obvious reasons
three temperatures in one action makes
it easy to grab a bonus then we got
giant solar shade and I have to stress
this card must be used to get the Terra
bonus on the Venus scale you have to do
this and then we've got the strip mine
this cast can definitely be used to grab
the bonus on the oxygen scale notably it
is the only thing in the game that
actually gives you two oxygen at once in
one action but you can also play this
card a lot earlier because of its engine
making capabilities so both are gems are
good and number two don't give your
opponents an easy way to claim the
bonuses making a play that just leaves
the parameter one or even Two Steps From
a bonus is something you really should
avoid if possible number three plan your
accent carefully especially when you're
getting close to a bonus number four if
you are the first player in the Next
Generation you can actually use this
generation to set yourself up to grab
the bonus at the start of the next
Generations this is due to the fact that
you'll have more actions in a row if you
end this generation and also start the
upcoming generation so just like poker
play order actually does matter in this
game tip number five prioritize
Milestones sooner in short game 4 and 5
player games in Long games Milestones
are less important in two and three play
games once again I will elaborate on
this in episode 6 here are the
Milestones on the original map because 8
it gives you 5 victory points at the end
of the game here the milestones for the
healers and Elysium maps and technically
we are now also talking about the first
award because that also cost 8. so here
are the awards from the base game
although I would say that it is actually
really dangerous to start on the war
early on it's hard to predict who wins
so if you are going to start the first
award you must have a really really good
feeling that you're gonna win it but
regarding milestones in the early game
you should always have milestones in
mind and you should always try to get at
least one of them I think we can all
agree in this but with that out of the
way I think there's still a little bit
of wiggle room here regarding when to
buy them so bear with me here basically
milestones and possibly maybe the first
award should be bored when you are in
the 9th to the the last generation which
means that Milestones are less important
in two player games because usually two
play games a longer and the scores a lot
higher so I would argue that you should
wait until generation 5 or maybe even
later before your contest milestone in
two player games in fact if I do see my
opponent just rushing to get all the
milestones in a two-player game I'm
actually fine with it honestly you can
have them because I know that this is 24
Mega credits he's not spending on engine
and I'm pretty confident that the 24
megaforate that I then instead will be
spending on engine will amount to more
than the 15 points he's getting in three
player games fight for the milestones in
the first award on Generation 4 in 4
player games fight for the Milestones of
the first awarded generation 3. in 5
player games basically fight for them as
soon as possible in 5 pair games it is
actually a Race So I think this is a hot
take I'm pretty sure a lot of you is
going to disagree with me on this one as
I think a lot of people just feels that
the Milestone is a race and this should
just be cleaned as soon as possible and
I mean if you can't get a milestone
early and you still have money to get
your engine up and running then it is of
course entirely reasonable it also
depends on your average score I would
say like if your average score is 50
victory points then a milestone is very
important because five victory points is
a huge chunk of your score it's gonna be
10 however if your average score is
165 points and this is probably only
usually your score and two player games
to be honest but if your score is like
this High then the five victory points
for the Milestone is only three percent
of your score on a side note if you do
get scores this High you probably know
how to turn 8 Mega Credit in the early
game into five Victory Point by the end
tip number 5.5 do not make too many bad
plays just so you can get a milestone
instead rather go for the Milestones
that naturally fits your game like if
you're playing thesis naturally you go
for the Maya Milestone and so on if you
have to make like one sub-optimal play
to get a milestone then maybe it's okay
but just to give you an example if you
start the game playing the early
settlement Prelude and then you play
Phobos basehaven then you're like hmm I
I only need one more City to get the
Mayo Milestone and then you do a build a
city standard project for 25 and then
you get the meow Milestone or something
dumb like this then you are in fact
going to lose like because what have you
just done you've just spent a Prelude
and 61 Mega credit just to get a total
of eight victory points and make a
credit production at sustaining
production on plant production and Grant
that you are getting a little bit of
production but this is nowhere near
worth it it's not efficient tip number
six don't buy the Milestones until an
opponent is three actions from buying
the same Milestone or three actions away
from claiming the last available
Milestone slot or technically you know
if two players are close to getting the
last two Milestone slots also this but
the point is that it is technically
correct to wait for as long as possible
before you claim the Milestone even if
you have fulfilled the requirement the
reason is that Mega credit is worth more
early compared to later on so if you
can't get away with waiting you should
wait sometimes it happens that your
opponent just gives up because disease
that you fulfilled requirements so then
he's got to focus on other things and
then maybe you just get away with just
waiting like four generations before you
actually buy it and that feels really
good so this is what I recommend unless
of course you don't want to keep track
of when your opponents are exactly three
actions away from buying a milestone in
that case you can just claim them all
them soon and you know what this is
actually completely legitimate like so
much stuff going on in terraforming
masks so if you just want to claim it Go
and claim it but technically it is more
correct to actually wait for as long as
possible and obviously the reason that
it's exactly when your opponents is
three actions away that that is because
you only have two actions on your turn
if you don't have two actions you can't
get the Milestone when it's three
actions away tip number seven plan out
your generation do the math okay so
let's get this one out of the way in
both games in general you will do better
if you do the math in your head and you
plan your turns and so on unfortunately
this is especially true for terraforming
masks there's no denying that this is a
method game in some people's mind this
is the biggest weakness of the game not
me of course I [\h__\h] love math but I
can appreciate that some people do not
enjoy crunching the numbers all the time
you don't really have to do the math but
if you want to here's the most important
things to math out in my opinion this is
the math that I do in my head every
single generation usually
even before the research phase before
you get to buy four cards even before
this I usually plan out which cards and
other stuff I plan to do in the upcoming
generation
then if one of the four available cards
present me with a better plan then of
course I just changed my plan but
usually if you have a very expensive
card on your hand this can be useful so
if let's say you have Earth elevator
then I might even start the math in the
generation before because Earth elevator
is so goddamn expensive so sometimes you
just have to pass the generation with a
decent amount of Mega credit and
titanium so you can play some of these
expensive cards in the Next Generation
could also be the giant solar shade and
like we mentioned please use this card
to get the one Tierra bonus and the
Venus scale it could also be i o mining
Industries this is like the Jovian
amplifier you want to play sort of early
on because it gives a good amount of
engine so the math itself is pretty
simple actually if you do the math on
the generation before it is simply your
current amount of Mega credit plus the
mega credit production plus whatever
else you can generate make a credit
somehow minus the stuff you plan on
spending make a credit on in the
upcoming generation cards or colonies
whatever it might be and then of course
you also take into account steel and
titanium steel and titanium are implied
in this case the number you're left with
should be above zero or more precisely
it should actually be like 9 or 12. the
reason I like doing it this way is
because then I know exactly how many
cards I can afford to buy in the
research phase does it make sense like
if the math adds up to six or nine then
I'm know that I can restrain myself to
only buying two or three cards so this
is just the math that I do in my head I
think a lot of people do this actually
other examples of math I do is for
example when I play a card I calculate
how many generations it will take for
the car to pay for itself and then to
take into account how far in the game we
actually are like I mentioned engine
build a car should pay for themselves in
five generations of viewer but the later
in the game we get in terms of
generations the faster a card must be
able to pay for itself then in the late
game I simply calculate which of my
available plays Will generate the most
amount of VP like does this card here
give you enough VP for your bug or does
it give more VP if you simply start
spamming CDs and greeneries we are now
bleeding over to the realm of completely
obvious I'm gonna move on now so do you
need to do all of this math when you
play terraforming Mars new plenty of
people actually do quite well just based
on intuition alone on other subconscious
level they probably still consider these
things does it help to do all of this
math yes yes it does tip number eight
aim for the greedy long game or a short
Tiara heavy game first of all let's look
at how long a typical game of
terraforming Mars usually is gonna be in
a two-player game the games will last
for like 11 to 14 Generations mostly at
least a vast majority of games will if
you ever see a game go to 15th
generation it's because both players are
just Omega greedy having fun with a
super huge engine and both players
collectively just refuse to close the
game I've only tried this once and I can
actually show you that like the only
reason I let this game go to 15
Generations is because I just wanted to
see how much heat and playing production
I could get just for the memes really
five player games will last like 7 to 10
Generations mostly it is a bit harder to
predict because in five player games it
really comes down to how much the
players are around the table really
wants to terraform I've seen a five
player game go to 12 generations and
I've seen a five player game being
closed out already at Generation 6 and
on a side note this sucks man haven't
you came close out so fast is just no
fun at all this is why personally I
prefer two or three player games it's
much more engine much more greed much
more card bro much more fun so think
about the overall strategy the overall
game plan aim for the greedy long game
or aim for the short game where you just
get a bunch of TR and punish your
enemies for making this big engine this
is the nice push and pull aspect of
terraforming Mouse basically there are
four different ways that every single
terraforming mask game can shape out so
number one you got the greedy engine and
you want the game to drag out basically
you have the big engine you have a lot
of money income and a lot of card draw
so it is in your best interest that the
game dragged on for as long as possible
so this is full grade it's my favorite
if you have full grid mode you should
identify apply the last parameter to
close and just never terraform that
unless there's a bonus then then it's a
maybe number two your opponent has the
greedy engine so in this case it is in
your best interest to just close the
game as soon as possible like let's say
your opponent has the bigger engine
here's more card draw
then often you want to close the game
sooner rather than later the greedy
player will always make the most points
in the last generation and then if you
allow the game to drag out for even more
Generations then he's gonna Crush you
now let me be clear this strategy of
closing the game really early it is
severely boring and you will be hated
and you should be hated for closing the
game this fast however this might just
be the strategy you have to use if you
want to beat an opponent who has a lot
more engine and cut rather you have so
this is how you actually counter the
greedy players you won't always be
successful sometimes the greedy guy
still wins but it is often your best bit
to just end the game as soon as possible
alternatively we can look at number
three where you actually try to outgreet
your greedy opponent either you have a
big engine yourself and you will try to
to upgrade your greedy opponent and
compete with him in the ultra late game
it could also be the case that you had a
bad start and you see that your
opponents is going for the long game and
then you just try to do the same and see
if you can get some nice comeback cards
Like Satellites and stuff and then you
just still try to win the Uber late game
great wall and finally number four all
players try to close the game as soon as
possible and everyone races just to get
the most here as soon as possible and
this one never happens I've never seen a
game where this actually well probably
also because I'm I fill in all the games
that I've seen but in my opinion it
never happens there's there's no way
everyone around disabled is this [\h__\h]
boring the point is you want to identify
how long the game is going to last in
terms of generations and then you want
to plan accordingly you also want to
look at who's got the bigger engine like
as a rule of thumb if you've got the
bigger engine mod incoming cards you
want a long game if your opponent's got
the bigger engine money incoming cards
you want to close the game so
determining how long the game is going
to be in terms of generation it's
actually really useful so how can we
determine this first of all and I'm
serious about this I want you to count
the number of players in the game you
might think that this is not important
but in terraforming Mars it makes a huge
difference how many players are actually
in the game now the reason that the
number of players matter so much is that
the game will end when the three
parameters are satisfied like the water
the oxygen and the temperature the
number of required step to close the
game stay the same regardless of player
number which means that if you're in a
five player game where everyone is like
eager to terraform to get them due to tr
then the game is gonna be just over a
lot sooner in terms of generation
secondly you want to look at your
opponents what are they doing in the
first few Generations so in Generation 3
let's say you have to look at your
opponent's heat and playing production
when you see the corporations and the
the plain production the heat production
you can actually get a pretty good feel
for what they are going to do this game
are they going for the long game are
they just wanting to terraform as crazy
as possible to be precise you should
look at the parameter that is getting
the least terraformed and then you can
try to get a feel for how long the game
is going to be based on that but just be
mindful that when the water is about to
close the naturally people getting a lot
of plants and when the temperature is
about to close then people get a free
water and then they can also play the
late game plan cards it's not always as
easy to predict but you still get a
pretty good feeling for it here's a tip
like if you see someone placed a letter
early or ghg producing bacteria a
regular eaters then chances are the game
is probably not going to be super long
some corporations also gives an
indication of how fast people are going
to close the game if they play Omni or
equiline or recycling well then probably
the game is not gonna be lasting that
long because then it's a pretty good
indication that your opponent really
wants to terraform this game if you are
in a four or five player game you have
to make the transition from money engine
to VP grabbing a lot sooner if you spend
the entire game just making engine and
you don't make a transition from greedy
engine to VB grabbing in time and then
the game just ends a lot sooner than you
would have liked then that means that
you are going to lose so like we
mentioned this is why you want to think
about VP and TR pretty early on like as
a rule you really should go for VP like
when there's four generations left in
the game but then if you're on a five
player game it could be pretty soon
right if the game only lasts for seven
generations and so already two or three
generations into the game you have to
think about how am I actually gonna get
some VP with that being said engine is
is still number one but just keep this
in mind on the other hand if you want a
two or three player game you can afford
to be a lot greedier in fact I think you
should be a little Creed here just to
clarify grieve in my opinion is having
the biggest money engine known to man
and greed is playing a lot of cards
which brings me too tip number 8.5 if
you are in a two or three player game
you should always aim to play the greedy
card strategy every single game the
greedy card strategy can also work in
four to five player games but it just
it's it's a little more risky right
because the game just might end a lot
sooner than you would have liked playing
a ton of terraform Mass game I've just
come to the realization that the greedy
card strategy is simply the best
strategy in two to three player games so
at the very least you should always aim
to play the strategy then if you have no
luck getting engine not card draw and
stuff like this in the first to three
generations then fine you can think
about making a new plan but this is
really how I approach every single game
in a two or three player game on the
other hand in a four or five player game
sometimes I'll go for the greedy engine
anyway but I might just go all in on
another strategy like cities or
terraforming in a two or three player
games the card strategy is just Superior
I think like when you think about it if
you can get away with playing this
greedy card strategy then it's just a
stepping stone to every other strategy
in the game maybe except for the
terraforming strategy what I mean is in
the games where I've been successful in
going god mode
I quite naturally just picked up a ton
of cities energetic cards and Joven
amplifiers and so on so the greedy card
strategy and going guard mode this is
also how you can generate the biggest
crazy scores literally every time I've
gotten 200 plus it is with this greedy
card strategy when you go God mode tip
number nine get heat production in the
early to mid game or actually maybe
never never is also fine in the first
few generation heal and plan production
have to be secondary money income is
more important in my opinion you should
look at heat and plant production after
you've gotten at least plus 10 money
income so like earlier we talked about
the importance of money income in the
early game then you might be thinking
what about plans what about heat isn't
this also a way to build your engine and
while you technically might be right
it's just uh it has to be secondary like
it takes eight heat a plant just to get
one money income because of the one
Tierra you're getting for terraforming
to put it simply plants are just not
very efficient ways of generating in
Gold this is why this card designed
microorganisms can be a trap sometimes
plant and heat production is okay at the
start of the game if you already have
like a decent chunk of money income
going for you I would say at least plus
10 or that would be 30 if you if you
counted starting 20 Tierra the more the
better of course but at the very least I
think you should have 10 additional
money income at the start of the game
it's really desperately needed once you
have plus 10 money income then you will
get the official boneless Green Tech
green light and then you may buy stuff
like design microorganisms of course if
you literally have no money in Comcast
in your hand then getting plan and here
production is fine like you have to play
with the cards you've been dealt or do
you what if you're playing with colonies
just to give you an example so in the
first generation if I have the choice
between building a colony on Luna for 70
Mega credit with a standard project or I
could play import of advanced ghg for 9
Mega credits plus three for the cast
that's 12. I know that Luna is then
technically five more Mega credit
but nevertheless I will choose Luna
every single time like it's not even
close don't get me wrong heat and plane
production is actually not that bad it's
actually not that hard to get it heat
but at the same time it's just a very
slow way to build your engine so what is
heat worth we looked at this briefly in
tip number one but in the first
generation I'm willing to be generous
and say that one heat production is
worth five Mega credit and and this
might even be generous then we also run
into the problem that you kinda also
just want to spend the first few
Generations on money income so this
makes it a little bit awkward but in the
first half of the game while the
temperature parameter is fairly low then
heat production is worth maybe four Mega
credits and then you also have to look
at your opponent's here production if
they have like a ton of heat production
then your heat production is going to be
worthless but then at the same time
maybe you are denying them a couple of
TR so you know it's a trade-off if you
are the only one with heat production
then it is worth maybe a little more so
if you paste it on my estimated value
which to be clear listening to me is a
dubious proposition Abyss then the heat
production cards in general are a little
bit underwhelming so heat production can
be a trap it's awkward that heat will
only give a few TR and then the
temperature is just maxed and then your
heat is completely useless compare that
to plants plants are still good after
the oxygen skill have been maxed it
gives you VP so remember the value of a
card is three Mega grit so for instance
if you buy mohal area then you are
giving a little more than 5 Mega credit
per heat production then you also get a
placement bonus so let's say it's a flat
5 Mega credit per hit production so it's
it's not great but I mean you still play
this sometimes this goes into the if if
I have no good cards I might as well
play this and I will say that the four
heat production is actually a good
number it only takes two generations to
gate at the eight heat so this is
actually reasonable and then we got
soleta pretty much the same story it's a
little more than five Mega credit per
heat production but it is very expensive
and seven is an awkward number so you
would need like a little more to bring
it to 80 production per generation but
man this is a lot of work I'm not a big
fan to be honest the only redeeming
factor of mohol area is a letter to be
honest it is that you can use steel and
titanium when buying them then we have
Micro Mills holy six Mega credits just
for one heat production
yeah this is not a good card only buy
this if you have exactly save and heat
production you conduct use this card to
balance your heat production in a way so
you always get to 8 or 16 or whatever it
might be in that case it might be all
right but
I wouldn't probably never buy this car
if I get this car for free maybe I will
play it but it's very I don't think I've
ever actually bought this car it's it's
not worth buying I think so as you
probably can hear my view on heat
production is not good it's pretty bleak
I would say that some of my terraforming
Mouse friends actually hold heat in even
lower regard than I do but fear not
there is actually a place for heat
production and terraforming Mass so when
is heat production good if you played
early well you have to play it early but
then at the same time you also want
money income in the early game so it
it's a little bit awkward but it is of
course better if you play it early
number two you are trying to close the
game early in the previous chapter we
talked about this can be a useful idea
in order to punish the guy with greedy
engine so if you are other terraforma if
you want the game to close early then
obviously heat production can be quite
nice for this purpose number three if
you have a heat combo heat is okay if
you have a combo so let's look at some
of these combos first of all we got the
discount cards I am counting the
discount cards as a combo in this case I
put in optimal air braking and Media
Group because I find that these cards
combined with some of the heat
production cards Works quite nicely
together but really we could have just
mentioned any of the discount cards
really I almost didn't include this
because well discount cards are just
making all cards better right why is it
significant for heat production Cuts I
will say that I just feel that a lot of
these cards just fits the heat
production cards especially the cheap
ones and honestly just with a little bit
of help with a little bit of support a
little bit of discount or something then
some of the cheap heat production cards
are actually quite nice then we got melt
works one of the new promos sort of new
75 heat into three steel pretty nice
everyone knows the healing Corporation
and then we got okay I'll take a
contract and installation all of these
cards just solve the biggest problem of
heat production which is that as soon as
temperatures maxed heat production is
completely worthless well if you have
some of these cards in your hand maybe
it's not so worthless anymore you have
some use for your heat in the late game
then we got the thermalist award of
course and it's nice but just don't get
baited into thinking that heat
production is actually still good in the
late game just because you have the
thermalist award it's it's not that
important like we mentioned five VP is
not the biggest of deals and you
probably have to spend like 14 Mega
credit on starting this and you also run
into that someone else is taking this
award from you it could be that they
just get a ton of energy production
maybe they have some of the energy
production boosters and then maybe
they'll take it from you anyway but that
being said it is of course still nice
that this thermalist award exists it
fits this nicely right and finally if
you are playing with turmoil then there
is actually this really funny strategy
where you just go all in and heat
production and then you pump delegates
into the calvinist party because then
your heat production actually doubles as
Mega credit production it's a good uh
maybe I only played it like once or
twice but it was a lot of fun to be sure
the point is that you have to have one
of these combos then if you have one of
these combos then heat is actually not
that terrible just don't spend the first
two generations playing Solita and
nothing else and expect to win the game
someone once told me that the letter is
probably the best card you can have in
your opening hand and I have to
wholeheartedly but very respectfully
disagree if you have mega credit
production and you also can somehow
Place letter and you can also somehow
get plus one hit production additional
heat from energy or something so you
have 8 and not seven then it can be okay
but this is like a dream scenario and
this is even this is like not broken
this is just it's okay it's fine because
one free TR every generation that is
actually worth something that's actually
quite good brace yourselves I did a math
so if you have exactly eight heat
production then it is basically eight
Mega credit production if you think
about it because remember one TR is
worth eight Mega credits but then it has
to be exactly eight heat production and
then we also run into the problem that
when the temperature is maxed so it's a
little worse than this so maybe like
seven Mega credit production and even
this number might be generous unless you
have a heat combo so we are back to one
of these if you think about it it's
actually not too bad you have a use for
your heat in the late game so if you
have exactly 8 heat production then I
would argue that it is worth 1 TR per
generation which is also exactly eight
Mega credit production heat production
by itself is underwhelming but heat
production With a Little Help combo or
something then it's actually good it's
still not great but it's at least good
so overall I probably still would prefer
money and come in the early game but I
suppose it also comes down to the point
we discussed earlier that experienced
terraforming Mass players are maybe just
a little bit better at investing the
mega credits whereas there's very little
skill cap to using heat now I know what
you guys have been wondering about for
the last five minutes and yes this shirt
in the corner of the screen is in fact
the same shirt that I'm wearing right
now okay with this out of the way we can
go to plant production tip number 10 get
plain production in the mid game or at
the very least after you have built a
money engine now first of all let me
just make it clear that I think the plan
production is a whole lot better than
heat production you just have to play
the right cards at the right time a few
of my terraform you'll have friends with
like never buy plant production like you
you all know this guy that guy that guy
really hates plants like every group has
that one guy who would never in a
million years play a play and production
card even to save his life I think that
guy is kind of missing out but in
production can actually be quite good so
let's talk about the plane amplifiers
real quick if you play with colonies
then my favorite one is equality
research like if I get this car I might
just seriously change my strategy I just
focus on building all of the colonies
instead in one game I had this combo
this was my opening end it was crazy
it's ecology research standard
technology and then I had the Poseidon
Corporation I kept very few cards except
for these discards like only a few cards
that gave me gold production or
something and then I just bought all the
colonies for 14 gold right and then
after I've done that I just slammed the
color to research and I just I basically
crushed everyone that game here are the
rest of the planned amplifiers you might
think wait what why is vile enhances
here I think I kind of think this is a
planned amplifier in some games I have
gotten quite a lot of plans from the
Cars on average the other plan number
five probably will give you more plans
but then again violin henses is cheap
and it does give you a ton of other
stuff as well now as it is the case with
every single amplifier in the entire
game these cards are of course
situational that that's just the nature
of amplifiers in this game like it's not
every game you'll get three plant tags
so you could play nitrogen-rich asteroid
and get the juicy for playing production
but generally speaking I think all of
these cards are actually quite good
definitely above average
well maybe except for worms
unlike the other cards here I rarely get
good value from playing worms you need
one more microbe tag just to get one
plant production and that case is still
like a bit underwhelming if you get like
three micro attacks plus this one so you
get two plaque production that is
actually quite okay then it's a little
above whatever average but to not very
often that I have three micro attacks
and then I get to play worms to get to
play in production the rest of the cards
here are top tier though mostly I get
pretty good value from these cards I
think the sweet spot for win ticket plan
production is in the mid game don't get
it too early I don't think it's good I
would even go so far as to say having
one or two playing production in the
early game is actually bad in the early
game don't get play in production until
it adds up to three or more playing
production its plans are just not good
for building your engine having three
plant production in the early game is
okay is like almost good having four or
more playing production then it's
different that's okay full plan
production is in the unigame that that's
good enough because then it only takes
you two generations to make a Greenery
however it is really hard to get full
plan production maybe you have the dream
planned opening it could be equal line
or something or it could also be ecology
experts Prelude with farming or kelp
farming and side note naturally if you
do get freaking ecology experts with
kelp farming you just forget about
everything I just said and you just play
this every single time the value on this
combo is just so good so however in most
of the cases when you only have like one
or two player production in the
beginning then it's just not good it's
trash it's compost it's not good it has
three reasons why I think it's not good
to have one or two plant production in
the other game one this is money you
could have spent on money income and
playing production also tends to be
quite expensive especially in the early
game it does come become cheaper later
on when the requirements gets fulfilled
and so on and number two if you only
have one or two playing production in
the early game then it will take you
like four generations before you even
get one Greenery down and that one
Greenery is only going to generate you
one money income and reason number three
is this [\h__\h] guy like before you get
any Greenery though and your opponent's
gonna throw meteors and viruses which
just removes your plant if you only have
one or two plant production then chances
are you will lose your plans at some
point during the four generations that
take you to just get one Greenery down
what you could do is save some plant
production in your hand in order to play
them later but remember it can also be
quite risky to just keep stuff in your
hand that you're not soon to use because
the patterns alone cost three Mega
credit but sometimes it's definitely
worth it I actually tend to do this a
lot but you have to just be careful
you're not tanking your economy by doing
this plants are good later on and they
can actually be a great source of VP but
that is basically what they are a way to
get victory points and VP is something
you want to focus on in the mid to late
game green risk gives you three VP if
you place them next to a city so you get
one of the green itself one TR for the
oxygen and then you get one for the city
on top of that plant production usually
comes with some sort of green tag which
can provide even more VP first of all
the legal ad viewer will notice that
Viral enhancers has found its way into
this slide also but hold up Mr boneless
didn't you just say that while it has a
plan amplifier
but on top of that vile enhancer is also
an absolute VP monster like this is the
green tag equivalent of a durian
amplifier and it costs nine this card is
very good so just like plant production
I feel like the sweet spot for playing
all of these cards are in the mid game
and even if you play them in the mid
game these cards can still generate an
absolute ton of victory points well
maybe except for meat Industries
I will say though that even though meat
Industries doesn't give you victory
points it is still one of the best cards
in the game if you're having a good game
and you could get some nice Green Tech
Synergy up and running meat Industries
can just make you filthy rich same story
with GMO contract but this is turmoil
card and let's be honest who the hell
plays with turmo even though the mid
game is the sweet spot for plant
production cards then you still of
course want to play these really good
late game playing cards the value on
these cards are just insane which also
go hand in hand with the high
requirements so even though you might
not get so many plants out of these
cards you still play them the real
reason these cards are also really good
in the late game is you guessed it they
give victory points they all have
victory points attempts to them well
yeah I guess except for maybe
greenhouses
seriously though greenhouses are still a
really good carpet game or you can play
a little sooner to get the bonus on the
oxygen scale also works the last point I
want to make today is regarding the last
generation of the game in the last
generation plants is a wild card in the
last generation plants are worth
anything between 0 and 23 Mega credit
it's worth zero if the plant you're
getting does not push you over the eight
plan threshold and it's worth sort of
kind of 23 Mega credits if that one
planned out plant auction is just what
you need to make plus one Greenery in
the extra round and yes usually people
actually do buy the standard Greenery in
the last round for 23 Mega credits it
happened pretty often actually so
playing production in the last
generation is actually good it depends
of course how much you need to get that
plus one Greenery in the Easter round
you want to time it in a way so you just
get just enough to get that plus one
Greenery actually maybe you need a
little more why because of this [\h__\h]
guy
we all know this guy don't we the guy
that literally is just sitting with
cards like bird in his hand and then his
weight and weight and then he waits some
more he wait until you pass the last
generation and then he absolutely
Grieves You by removing one or two
playing production which it's just
exactly what you needed to make a
Greenery in an extra round it actually
does matter a lot like we discussed that
Greenery could easily be worth two or
three or maybe even four victory points
I gotta be honest I'm actually sometimes
the spirit person I'm guilty in the next
video we're going to discuss the
importance of slow playing in the last
generation one of the reasons is of
course that you want to slope in the
last generation then you are less likely
to be assaulted by this bird person
after it's too late to do anything about
it if you haven't passed yet maybe you
can get a plan somewhere like a
placement bonus or something I actually
decided to cut this video in two because
I feel like 10 tips was maybe easier to
digest than 20 tips and also because my
PowerPoint presentation kept question
big PB link to the video too in the
description goodbye